foreign
let's go to Spencer in Fresno California
what's up Spencer
hey John how are you doing we're rocking
dude what are you up to
oh just uh just surviving the Heat
is it hot there in Fresno
oh it's uh we're we're not close to the
ocean so it uh it heats up a lot all
right well it's beautiful here in
Nashville so haha I'm just kidding we'll
make it over one day there you go come
on over man everyone else in your
neighborhood's moved in so y'all should
join y'all should join us so what's up
dude
um my question for you
is I've had a gambling addiction
specifically to sports betting that's
rained havoc in my life for years
as I work on overcoming it I'm
struggling to find peace in my life and
also to find life fun and enjoyable to
live
how am I able to do that oh man
all right so you read that question
there right
I did all right so
just speak from your heart
what's been going on in the last few
years how long has this been going on
um close to about eight years okay
what's your total loss
um if I'm being honest I don't know
exactly because even as I've tried to go
back and look at it it's from so many
different places yes uh but but but
total my guess is somewhere between four
and five hundred thousand okay
when you say wreaked havoc
besides the financial losses or what
what is it what does it cost you
um I think I figured the financial
losses have obviously uh played effects
in other places My Life
um I think I have seen it more rain
havoc in my ability to wake up and enjoy
life every day and um I mean that in the
way of just
um interactions with my wife
interactions with my friends
um my ability to want to go do fun
things
I um I feel almost a little bit numb
to it and uh I think the scariest part
to me is as I've come back is
is learning to I think I live so much in
the past from my for my younger self my
high school self
that I uh that I I just wish that I
could go back to a time when I remember
times that were so fun living in the
moment yeah
how old are you man
I'm 25. 25.
hmm
so some broad
you mind if I teach first just like 30
seconds then we'll get back to your
situation because I want to paint a big
picture here okay absolutely
um
the last data point I read was
200 billion dollars in Wagers over the
last five to six years
to put that into context
if we spent 40 billion dollars until
that would end Global hunger
no more hungry people for 40 billion a
year for seven years
we've spent 200 billion dollars gambling
on sports or here's an even better one
it would cost about 20 billion dollars
to end homelessness in the United States
once and for all
yeah
210x we've blown gambling and here's
where it really I just makes me sick to
my stomach man because I I dude I I'm
heartbroken for you because you're an
addict right yeah I am and
but this is a different kind of
addiction because you know if you're a
Coke addict you go to jail right
uh you know if you're a Coke addict at
some point it kills you
yeah but we have the government and
educational agencies promoting this
as a good thing a way to help out your
community and have a little fun too
because
proceeds go to uh
government coffers and it goes to help
education
so it's kind of like taking cocaine in
fentanyl sales
for and donating that to the local
schools so they can get more Chromebooks
or whatever crap
yeah total it's just total BS dude and
it just it makes me sick
um
take me back to how this started man
yeah um I think in the beginning it
started uh I mean it started in all fun
I was in a I was in a really low point
in my life
what happened yeah
um I grew up in a really religious
family okay and um great relationship
with my family and great relationship
with my parents but
um I ended up going on a mission with my
church
and uh anyway I came back earlier than I
thought I would did you get in trouble
earlier no not in trouble just due to
mental health just with um uh issues
with depression okay anxiety whereas if
my body wasn't functioning
like it should be anyway I uh I went
home and I just felt a lot of Shame and
a lot of guilt in my life for not being
able to complete that okay
and uh was that guilt in shame
reinforced by your parents and Friends
um
by my friends I
over time my parents have learned a
little bit more of how to deal with it
but when I came home I was supposed to
be out there for close to two years and
I came back after six months okay
and uh so no one was really expecting it
and uh my siblings you know they all
welcome and then I think my parents they
were just a little bit more like what
are you doing that type thing
um
and so I think that was hard so instead
of ever like facing anything or instead
of going out I I just didn't want to
leave the house and I ended up going
over to my sisters who lived in South
Carolina
and uh I stayed with her and while I was
over there she was she was just telling
me you know every Sunday
they just bet on a football game while
it plays and I was like that's awesome
and uh you know they were they were just
betting a couple of bucks and anyway
ever since that day I uh it became my
comfort
and it became the thing I went to every
time because I I think I felt very
abandoned in that time in my life
um so over time it just it became my
crutch and um can I be honest can I be
honest with you please I I think you
were probably felt abandoned before that
I tend to
I like to start at a place when I hear
somebody say I'm really struggling with
depression anxiety I needed to come home
I like to start from a place that your
body was doing exactly what it needed to
do to keep you safe
not that it was malfunctioning
or wasn't working as it should
and that would lead me to believe that
there was some sort of Preparatory
challenges I mean there was some sort of
environment that wasn't set up before
you left
there wasn't deep anchors and Deep Roots
so that you can go do something really
hard like a two-year Mission at 18 years
old that's tough man that's scary that's
isolating it's all that stuff and you've
got to be anchored into something way
bigger than you
yeah am I right
um yeah I mean it's hard because
I feel like I had good support from my
family okay
um and I had a really good friend group
I think I think as growing up I was
always like a really small kid it wasn't
until I turned about 20 that I actually
grew and
but I mean all through I I always felt
like I was like the little sibling even
in high school and even coming out I was
always the guy that that looked six
years younger than he was and so I I
don't think I ever really felt like I
was a real friend I always felt like I
was the Friend's Brother okay
so you've always been on the outside
looking in we always felt like on the
outside looking in and even if people
invited you because they liked you you
had another story as to why they weren't
really inviting you because they liked
you
and you got a brain screaming at you
dude we got to plug in we got to plug in
we got to plug in and then you go off to
another country you go off to another
state where you know nobody and they say
go get them
yeah man I mean that's that's I mean
it's a recipe for anxiety it's a recipe
for a body shutting the system down
and then you come back and then were you
18 when you came back
yeah I was yeah and then your sister
handed you a a double uh double Jack and
Coke and was like hey we just do this on
Sundays and your body went ah right
yeah yeah man
what do you do for a living
um I work in uh cells so if you do you
make a whole bunch of money or have you
have you mortgaged and leveraged your
soul
um no I I actually make a really good
income okay and I think that's the part
that is hard is I think sometimes I bang
my head against the wall where I'm like
it doesn't really matter what I make
because it's just all going down the
drain anyway I know but there's there's
listeners that if they gambled 500 000
over seven years that would mean they've
taken out two mortgages and they've
stolen money but if you make 250 000 a
year over seven years you can blow that
kind of money
right no it's it's something I'm able to
on the financial part
um I'll I'll be out of debt here in the
next about uh two months okay
um tell me about your marriage bro
um it's great my wife's fantastic
um I'm I've been only married for nine
months
does she know the extent of this
um she has and I've more not when we
first got married
um I had brought it up to her but
um
I think I think it was hard that I
wanted her to pry more than she would
and so it just kind of got left on the
doorstep and I said hey I have kind of a
problem with this and you know she said
thanks for letting me know but she never
asked me additional questions
um since then I've realized that if I
ever want to make a change in my life I
can't wait for somebody else to come to
me
um well hold on bro that's I mean you
kind of presented like the Bro Flex out
version
you're right you've got to be honest
about it right but yeah
you can't White Knuckle your way through
this
yeah
and you can't you can't over discipline
your way through this and I'm a guy that
really preaches discipline because I
think in a lot of areas
man if people just sleep and they would
have great friends and be disciplined
about exercise a lot of their life's
problems would would shift this is not
one of those moments
yeah
I think I think recently I've realized
that a little bit in the past
a little while and I and I realized that
I'm just so poor with with money and
where it's going and so
um I my wife's just I mean
she doesn't have the same addictions
that I do Spencer the way you just said
that is like saying yeah I just realized
that I have a problem with
um
cocaine and how much of it just gets in
my nose
yeah
you are over your head man
and until you're ready to fully submit
this thing's gonna keep growing like a
dragon
yeah
I
um
the first steps I've done is uh I gave
my wife all of
um my debit and my credit cards and I
gave her everything
and I said hey set me up on a couple
hundred week budget Mac just for you
know food and gas
and then uh and then that way for right
now we can both see the accounts that I
only have access to a couple hundred
bucks
and uh that will work for about eight
weeks for you
nope it won't it will work for about
four weeks for you
yeah and I think that's the part that
I'm nervous about
I'm telling you right now Spencer you
you are bro dude you are
doing everything you can to avoid the
reality of this
and that's that's totally fine that's
totally fine
how do I not avoid it you sit down and
tell your wife honey I am in full-blown
addict
I haven't been fully honest with you I
cannot control this
I've been gambling for seven years since
I was a kid
I'm struggling with depression I'm
struggling with anxiety and this is
every bit a um getting drunk every day
of my life
or every bit doing heroin every day of
my life
and I've got to start going to GA gamble
is anonymous
I got to get a group I don't have to get
a sponsor because I'm over my head and
I'm sorry I didn't tell you the truth
that's where you got started
yeah anything short of that my friend
you're too smart you make too much money
you're trying to do gentle workarounds
with a beautiful wife who doesn't know
how bad this is
yeah
Fair
that's fair
I think that uh I think that's after a
while too you lie to yourself for so
long of course you do yeah man
and uh I guess like I don't know too
because I've sat down with my wife and
when I when I basically said hey you
need to take all the cards away I told
her that
uh you know I was like I like I'm an
addict and I can't control this
um
but I know as addicts do that even in
ways that I don't know if you really
want to do it
you'll find a way to find a way you've
set yourself up to commit a crime
or you've set yourself up to really
violate a core tenet of your marriage
which is we will tell the truth to one
another
yeah because you put boundaries in place
without dealing with the core issue
yeah
the core issue I I always look at
addiction any sort of addiction as
whether it's work or whether it's drugs
or whether it's gambling or sex whatever
it happens to be it that's relational in
origin
and until you deal with that black hole
man this little kid that doesn't feel
like he's enough and feels like he's on
the outside and feels like he's a burden
and feels like
um he just has to
accomplish and Achieve so we can get
love around him and he failed this big
accomplishment and achievement that
everyone talked about since the day he
was born until he was 18.
until you deal with that
and the grief around that and the wait a
minute I don't suck I'm not a piece of
crap
I'm a good man I work hard I love my
family
until you deal with those things brother
Nothing's Gonna taste right
yeah of course you're not you're you're
not gonna
be able to see a vision of your life
with happiness and laughter and joy
yeah I promise you it's there
but you can't end around it you got to
go through it
how do I
to go back and say Hey I want to deal
with these issues and these core issues
from growing up
where would where would someone like me
start Gamblers Anonymous
you have to you have to be honest out
loud with a group of people who will
look Square through you
who won't put up with any of you if
you've been gambling like this for this
long and you're a world-class salesman
you can tell anybody anything right
yeah yes
you are a Wordsmith if there ever was
one you're Shakespeare and so you've got
to sit in a room with people who
they will sit back and look at you and
you will know that they know
and then you got to be honest
and then you're going to hear a bunch of
other stories and you're gonna go whoa
that's me too
and then you're gonna have people that
you call
at four in the morning when you can't
sleep and you're out of town on a sales
thing and you are logging into your
computer or picking up your phone and
you re you re-uh download those apps
and you got somebody looks in the eye
and says I will be here for you 24 7
365. I love you that much you call me
and then you're going to get to the core
issue of what happens just before you
get that impulse to gamble
yeah yeah and that's what you got to
lock in on that just takes time there is
no way to think your way through it
because you look dude you know this is
ruining things
you know
I do know there's not a way to think it
out
you gotta just walk through and face the
dragon and you cannot do that alone
and you especially can't do it with some
wife who's nine months in who's trying
to love you the best she can but she
does not know what she's in for
yeah Fair
that's fair I haven't met somebody who's
a full like full-blown over their head
into something
who is fully laid out everything in
front of his wife
I don't I don't know that guy until
they're ready to get stone sober when's
the last time you gambled
um about two weeks ago
when's the last time you really gambled
two weeks ago like for real though
that's the last time I did it what was
it on
it was on a uh a soccer match how much
um it spread out between a few different
sites but it probably would have been
about fifteen hundred dollars total okay
are you starting to itch now
um
it's hard I don't but
I've gone in Cycles my whole life when I
go too much into debt
then the edge wears down but as soon as
there's money The Edge just skyrockets
and uh I'm at a point where I'm in debt
and I don't have uh I don't have money
and that's when I basically given
everything over but I I think that's
again what scares me is when money
starts flowing
there you go now's the moment
yeah I had a I had a professor one time
she told me the hardest part about the
worst part about counseling is
people
people wait until things are on fire
before they go she said it's like
waiting till you get the flu to go to
the gym for the first day to start your
workout program that's the worst that
you're sick the best day to go to the
gym is when you feel great the best time
to start going to counseling is when
things are awesome and you can actually
hear and start practicing things and
you're not running for your life you
have a moment where you don't have any
money you're broke you're in debt you're
in a hole and you're embarrassed and
you're ashamed of it and you're not
going to gamble in these moments because
your body's
telling you I mean you're lucky on that
one because I've talked to Gamblers who
they'll they'll borrow and just borrow
until they got a steal and whatever
you're not there for whatever reason now
is a perfect moment
so before the day's over brother
before the day is over
you pull out your phone and you find the
local Gamblers Anonymous in your area
or a local CA group or if you have to
and all they have is a local AAA group
go there
you have to take a knee in front of a
group of men and women who have been
there and can see you and say we know
and we'll walk with you
and then at some point you're gonna have
to go with a licensed counselor who
knows what they're doing and start to
walk back this idea that you somehow
don't belong to anybody anywhere at any
time because it's not true you do
you're one of my friends now
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of blowing your past change your
future we're gonna hook you up with that
and then brother I will walk with you
every step of the way
and here's what that means that means
you go to meetings and you call me in 30
days I want to hear an update and I'll
be willing to update everybody out there
if you go to meetings every day for the
next 30 days I would love that
I'll also be here if you choose to get
off the line and you are about to make
the call tonight you don't make it
in six months when your wife finally
finds out how bad this is I'll be here
then too
I'm in the Long Haul with you I'll I'll
take your call every time you call man
but you got some hard choices to make
ahead of you and I hope you'll look in
the mirror and say dude Spencer's worth
being well dispenser's worth being whole
I'll talk to you soon my brother